[music]
[music and singing]
>> I know you saying what they told you.
>> Okay, okay, let me let me say this. Let
me say this. Let me say this in my
defense.
>> Because you can't you can't do a right.
>> no, no, let me say this in my defense.
Let me say this in my [laughter]
defense. He got it. He got it. He got
it. Let's see. Let me say this in my
defense, okay?
I know it's not Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John because
Jesus only got one book. He got one
book. It was one book and that's in
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John is four
books. So so
I know the Injil is one book and
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John are four
books. So How do you know that the the
Gospel only contains one book?
Like for example, the the Jews and
Christians, they're called people of the
book, right?
>> Right. So that's using book singular.
Sure.
But the Jews and Do Jews hold uh to the
Gospel?
Do they hold to the Gospel?
Uh they don't believe in Jesus. Right.
They don't believe in Jesus. They reject
the Gospel, but the Quran still lumps
them together as people of the book even
though it's talking about the Torah and
the Gospel. Talking about two books.
So even though Jesus has revealed a book
or the Gospel, a book, still within that
book can be a collection.
You know what I'm saying?
Um
Maybe. Maybe. Just like the Torah
>> I kind of see what you're Torah is
multiple books, but it's called one
book.
So so you're saying because the Jews and
Christians are referred to as the people
of the book, Mhm. right? That that
implies that I mean that that's kind of
your interpretation of what people of
the book means, right? Isn't it? Because
you're saying that that necessarily
means that that book contains other
other books.
>> It literally does cuz they're Jews and
Christians.
>> But you agreed with that earlier.
You agreed that the Jews don't believe
in Jesus. Yeah, they don't.
>> Right. So the Jews don't believe in the
Injil. They don't.
>> Right. And the Christians, they don't
necessarily have to follow the Torah as
like how the Jews was, right?
Well, they they
I I maybe maybe I don't know.
>> Right. But they put them but your Quran
put them together as one singular group
of people but with multiple books. The
people of the book.
>> Yeah. One book.
>> It's referring to multiple books as the
book, the one book.
>> See what I mean?
Okay okay. Well, I don't know. Maybe
that's just your interpretation of it.
Maybe that's just your You agree with
that? No no no no no. That that's that's
Can you hear me, homie? No, but but see
see Are you Do you live in I've I've
heard
Muslims say
okay Mhm. that the Injil
revealed to Jesus is only
one one book. Yeah, that's what they
say.
>> Like like like the analogy would be like
like the Quran. Like how this Quran is
one book and it was revealed unto
Prophet Muhammad. Yeah. Peace be upon
him. Yeah. Jesus got the Injil which was
one book and now it is to this book
But how do how do you know that it's
analogous?
How do you know it's the same way?
How do I know it's the same way? Yeah.
Um
How do you know that the way that Jesus
received the gospel is the same way that
that Muhammad received the Quran?
Couldn't they be completely different
ways that they received their
revelation?
I I suppose you're right. It It It could
be It could be different ways. So so so
saying that oh, well because what we
have is a collection of writings like
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
>> Yes. and you're calling it the gospel
that therefore disqualifies that from
being the Injil, that's not a good
critique because the Injil could be a
collection of writings. Okay. So so let
me ask you let me ask you a question.
Yeah.
Do Do you think
um
the
So so you So you think the Injil is is
is just the four gospels or the entire
New Testament?
>> Well, that's that's a good question
because
um
you know, if if I was if I'm being
charitable with the Quran saying that
the Injil is something that was revealed
to Jesus or given to Jesus, then if I'm
being charitable, I would limit it to
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John cuz they
wrote the the gospel of Jesus. Literally
Mark Mark's writing literally starts off
by saying, "This is the beginning of the
Injil or the gospel of Jesus Christ."
So, he's claiming to write the gospel of
Jesus, you know? So, yeah, I would limit
it to those writings since they are
writing the gospel. You got my phone?
Okay. Make sense?
>> Okay. Okay. So, so so it would just be
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. Yeah.
That's the gospel. Yeah, that's the
Injil. Yeah.
Uh
Okay. Uh Make sense? Yeah. I mean, I I I
I I understand what you're saying. I
understand what you're saying. Sure.
So, so going on with this point why this
is important cuz he's making a the the
the point that the Quran is confirming
what we have. It's not saying that what
we have is a distortion or a corruption.
This is a misconception that Muslims
have, but it's something that is
directly going against what the Quran
says.
And so, if we're going to let the Quran
speak, then you have to accept our book.
You have to. Or else you're going
against the law.
Okay. And so, so
You remember all those verses I showed
you what you say, "Well, I think you
just No, I'm showing you what the Quran
says. I'm not that that And if you look,
they're telling you something different
from what your Quran says.
Your Quran doesn't say what they say.
I showed you verses in the Quran that
they gave me. I didn't bring that Quran
with me. What What about where Allah
says um woe unto those who Write the
book with their own hands. Yes.
Claiming it's from God saying it's a
small price, right? Chapter 2 verse 79.
Yeah. Yeah. So,
notice what it says. It says, "Woe to
those who write the book with their own
hands claiming that what they wrote is
from God trying to sell it off for a
small price, right? So, that's like me,
if I write a book with my own hands, I
claim it's from God, and I try to sell
it off. Would that mean that the Quran
is corrupted? If I wrote a book today
with my own hands, claiming it's from
God?
Um
Would that mean the actual Quran is
corrupted?
>> No. Right. So, same way,
um you have these some of these people
who are writing books with their own
hands, claiming that these books are
from God, trying to sell it off.
But, that doesn't mean that the actual
Torah or the Gospels corrupted. It just
means that these people are writing fake
books.
>> think that's referring to the
the
>> Oh, no. No, no, no, no, no. Not at all.
>> of course you don't think it's referring
to the Bible, but but Like, yeah, if if
if I'm being like being consistent with
the Quran. Like, we're not putting our
own two like our own Christian lens.
Like, just based on what the Quran is
saying in that context, it's no, it's
not referring to the scriptures of the
Jews and Christians, but it's it is
referring to some of the people of the
Jews who are writing books with their
own hands, and claiming that what
they're writing is from God, putting it
above the Torah.
So, we have an example of that in actual
history. It's called the Talmud.
>> Talmud. Okay, so you you don't think the
Christians ever did that? No.
>> It never It never says that about the
Christians. Yeah. But But you do have in
history like you have uh heretical
Christians, we call them Gnostics, who
throughout history they used to come out
with uh hey, they used to come out Oh,
thanks, man. No problem. Yeah, have a
good day. You, too, bro.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Um the the Gnostics used to come out
with writings that they wrote with their
own hands, and would would uh forge
them, and even try to write like uh
disciples' names on them and stuff. And
they were called out, they were
rejected. You know? So, yeah, we do have
history of this, but somebody writing a
fake gospel or a fake, you know, writing
doesn't mean the actual Gospels tampered
with or corrupted, you know what I'm
saying? Okay, [snorts] so so how do you
know
that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
are not
like
uh
forgeries? Forgeries. Yes. Yeah, that's
a good question because throughout our
church history, we have You know how you
guys say that you guys have a chain of
narration with
Right, we have what is called a chain of
authorship. Or another word what they
would say is apostolic succession,
meaning people who succeed or come after
the apostles. Their students
[clears throat] and then their students
and then their students continuing to
pass down the tradition, right? So, in
our early church tradition and like the
Sahaba or the the Tabi'in, the
companions,
they're all in consensus and unanimous
that Matthew wrote Matthew, Luke wrote
Luke, John wrote John, and Mark wrote
Mark at the dictation of Peter. So, our
our church history is consistent on the
gospel authors.
You know, nobody even Nobody
I come from a long lineage of Middle
Eastern Christians. They always called
it Injil. Growing up, my grandfather,
his grandfather going back all the way
to Muhammad and past, Mhm. we always
called the New Testament Injil. Yeah,
that's nice. Nobody even considered it
to be forgeries until like Marcion,
which is like the 7th century, like 700
years later. That's when this
one guy who had a problem with Matthew
theology about whether it was that
Matthew didn't write Matthew and Mark
didn't write Mark. But, the early church
fathers, they they totally put him, you
know, put him straight and No, no, these
are the ones that actually
wrote these and scribed down these
books. It's never been a point that
where we where we didn't know who wrote
this Injil, this gospel. I think Marcion
was a 2nd century.
2nd century?
>> Yeah, I I I just looked it up.
>> Could have sworn he came a little later
than that. Yeah, but you know
>> right.
But, yeah, the bottom line is
>> Bottom line, didn't nobody contest He
was crazy. Yeah, nobody contested
So, the So the issue and the issue is is
the Quran affirms the scriptures we
have. It says it's a continuation of our
scriptures.
Uh it says we can find Muhammad
mentioned in our scriptures. And And
this is why we should recognize Muhammad
as a prophet. You know, we have no
excuse, you know? And so
>> [clears throat]
>> for for us, what we're going to What
we're doing is doing exactly what the
Quran is telling us to do. We're going
to use the gospel. We're going to use
the Torah. And we're going to judge by
it and see if Muhammad really is a
messenger. Does he actually line up with
the prophets? Does he line up with
Jesus? Does he line up with Moses? And
when we look at it, he contradicts them
at core doctrines, obviously. Like core
Jesus being the son of God. Um
uh the crucifixion, you know,
substitutionary atonement, right? So
putting God putting on the sins of the
world onto someone. Uh Muhammad
disagrees with all these things. But
this is what the Torah and gospel teach.
Well,
I would say uh
also Allah disagrees with Yeah.
>> all that stuff. Yeah.
That's That's the point. Yeah. Allah
shouldn't be able to disagree because
Allah is the one that said he revealed
these books.
That's even worse if Allah is the one
that disagreeing because now Allah
himself is
>> himself.
Okay.
Um
And you don't think God can contradict
himself, right?
No. Okay, so now something is off. You
You see the logic, right? You You
understand what we're saying. I Yes,
you're saying that
the Quran says that we have the the
Bible or or the
the Torah and the gospel. Yeah. And
because they say that Jesus is the son
of God and that he died on the cross,
that means that, you know,
they both can't be revealed from God, so
the Quran must be false. Exactly. So now
So now here's why. Because
since the Quran is saying these
scriptures are true,
if it contradicts true scriptures, then
that would mean the Quran is false.
Now, if these scriptures are corrupted,
even though like we got rid of that, but
let's even say that these scriptures are
corrupted at that time, then this would
mean that the Quran is confirming
corrupted books, which would still make
the Quran false.
>> Quran would still be false. So, really
the the crux of this argument seems to
be to be that
you believe the wise talking about when
he says the Torah
is uh
you know, what what the Jews currently
have, and you believe that what he's
referring to as the Gospel is like
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. Yeah.
Right? So, so
>> so
Okay.
Uh
I don't know. [snorts] There's no way
[clears throat] to disprove it that it
wasn't. There's no way
to disprove it.
Have anybody Nobody have ever read this
Injil
that you believe in. Nobody have read
this Injil Excuse me. that
they believe in.
Because every every thing if I was to
ask you, have you read this Injil?
The one that's not Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John that was given to Jesus. Have
you ever read it?
Well, I mean, I guess I I I guess I
would believe that like
it was lost or like Right.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John may
contain parts of it, statements from it.
Like here's here's the way I I kind of
think of it, right? Like
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
would be kind of like um
what we what we what we would call the
Sira,
right? That's that's kind of like what
those books are. They're they're it's a
it's a biography of a the the messenger,
Jesus, at that time. And you know, in
the case of the
Sira, it's it's Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him.
>> Right? So, I see the the Gospels as like
uh
analogous to the the Sira, right? Well,
how do you know the Injil wasn't that?
How do I know the Injil wasn't
>> wasn't a like a Sira type book?
Well, well, because because
um the only example that we have of a a
book from Allah
that's completely unaltered is the
Quran. So, I guess I guess I guess my
point would be that if if if if the uh
if if
if if if Christians really had the
Injil, I'd expect it to look similar to
what the the Quran is. Yeah, so Does
that make sense? I I we Yeah, so we we
understand your point of view. The
problem is is that there's a lot of
assumptions. Sure.
>> You're assuming a lot to for to to come
to that conclusion, right? And so I I
would say to kind of just open yourself
to the possibilities of the other things
that we brought up so that would you
know get rid of why you would disqualify
um Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John as
being the Injil cuz
all the evidence points to that. That's
all we have, you know? And so um
like if uh like here here's a here's a
good example. The Quran uh says that
Jesus was given the gospel, right? Now,
the question would be
was Jesus given a physical book or was
it kind of like how the Quran was given
to Muhammad like orally? What would you
say? I would assume it was a recitation
similar to what Muhammad Similar to
Quran, yeah, absolutely. And so so Jesus
wasn't walking around with a physical
book. He's going around preaching the
gospel orally, right? Which is exactly
what our our scriptures say, too. It
says Jesus was going around preaching
the gospel and it had his teachings. So
then the Quran later on is what he
showed you in chapter 7 157
is it talks about how the Injil and the
Torah are written books that have
Muhammad's description in them. And that
the Jews and Christians have these books
with them in Muhammad's time. So, at
some point, the Injil got written down,
right? So, there's a distinction between
the Injil, the oral Injil that Jesus is
preaching, and then the physical Injil
that got written down, right? Now, it's
obviously the same thing cuz it's
calling both the Injil, but they're just
different modes. One is orally, and one
is written, right? So, someone
wrote down the message that Jesus was
preaching,
right? They wrote down his words, right?
And it Who would you think would have
been the ones who wrote down his words?
Uh
Who do I think would have written down
Jesus' words?
>> Yeah. You had to give a guess. Yeah. Uh
Uh I don't know, man. Would you guess
his companions, like people who that
were close to him? His disciples. Yeah.
His disciples. Yeah. Same belief as us.
So, maybe the So, the disciples would
have written down his words. Could have
been during while he was preaching it,
or maybe a few years after, and they
were just recounting and just writing it
down. Who knows?
But, let's say So, his disciples are the
ones writing it down, right? And then
they get passed passed down to
generation to generation to generation.
So, then, if the disciples are writing
down what Jesus said and did, his
message, we would expect
this written document to include some
biographical information, like Jesus
went here and said this. Not
necessarily. I mean,
um
I mean, yeah, not necessarily. I mean,
Why not?
I mean,
what if they
what if they just wrote down
uh important statements of of of Christ?
>> Sure. But, they would But, they would
all they would all all have to say Jesus
said for you to know for them to depict
that in context Christ is speaking.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right? Maybe. Maybe. It's just like how
if you were to write down this event
right here, you would have to put in
certain things, like settings and places
and stuff like that, for people to get
the the general idea of what this
conversation is.
>> But you would say word said. Huh. And
what's your name, brother? Mark. Mark.
And then Mark replied, "Boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom." And then Avery
responded, "My name's Avery." Avery
responded, "Boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom." But that's that's that's kind of
an assumption, I feel like, because
you're assuming that it would
necessarily be a biographical format,
like it is in the gospels.
>> Sure, you may maybe not necessarily. I'm
saying that it could be that, though.
Maybe it doesn't have to be, but it
should it shouldn't surprise us if it is
that, right? Like, that wouldn't
disqualify from being the angel.
>> you're making an assumption, too.
You're making an assumption. You're
assuming that it must be in context and
similar revelation as the Quran, when
you have no evidence for that. You have
no evidence that it's have to look
similar to the Quran. You know what I'm
saying? So, you're making assumption as
well.
>> Okay. But our assumption is more
logical.
Our assumption actually fits into the
narrative. Your assumption, it don't,
because you don't have no other
evidence to go off of to even give your
assumption even credibility. Ours do. We
have what they have. You know what I'm
saying? We do have at least that, and
that's the only thing that's been known
through human history as the gospel is
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
So, history is on our side.
It's not on your side. You know what I'm
saying? So, your assumption is
plausible,
but it's not realistic.
Cuz you just that's just a
just an assumption that can
fall in any minute. Let me let me say
let me let me say this. Let me let me
say this.
Okay, as as I told you before, I've been
Muslim for
3 years?
So,
that that process started with me
actually reading the Quran. Okay. Okay?
When I read the Quran, I realized that,
you know, it had to a normal human being
couldn't have written it.
A normal human being couldn't have
written the Quran. That's what I
realized when I read it. Like the
information about, you know, people of
the past and about the Bible and and and
and and um
and and there were also certain
doctrines that I really latched onto
from it. I realized that this couldn't
be written by
someone like Prophet Muhammad.
>> How How did How did you verify that?
That like let's say for example when it
talked about the stories of the prophets
and stuff. How did you verify that the
Quran was getting that stuff right?
How did I verify that it was getting it
right?
>> Yeah.
Well,
well,
okay, let me let me back up a little
bit. So so so I guess I guess where I'm
coming from is that
when I read it, I didn't necessarily
know it was I didn't assume I it was the
truth before I read it. But what I'm
saying is like, you know, um
it's information that I don't think
somebody like Prophet Muhammad, given
his background that he cuz I cuz I knew
before I became Muslim that Prophet
Muhammad was illiterate and I don't
think this is something an illiterate
person could have could have come up
with on his own, all right?
>> But But he did he did it. I agree with
you that Muhammad didn't come up with
stuff on his own. They You know one of
his nickname is the ear?
The people The people that believed in
him used to call him the ear. You'll
find You want to know why?
>> everything. Cuz he he would hear things
and then repeat it.
He would repeat traditions. He would
repeat
uh For example, you know the story in in
of Jesus where it talks about him
creating a bird from clay?
Right.
>> That's in That's in a Gnostic Gospel
that existed hundreds of years before
Muhammad. It I think it's called the the
Infancy Gospel of Thomas. Is it the
Gospel Yeah. Yeah. The Infancy Gospel of
Thomas. That's That's And And Jesus
uh
uh speaking in the cradle, that's also
in another Gnostic Gospel.
>> Okay, so
see that's the problem. Like how did he
How did he get that information? Did he
write the Gospel?
>> No. It's It's It's word of mouth. It's
word of mouth. Muhammad was a He worked
with caravans and stuff like that. He
was a merchant. So
>> he got all of his information from
hearsay?
>> Yes. Yes. He He He uh Do you know who
Waraka is?
No. No? Okay, so so Waraka was his first
wife Khadija's um
I I want to say cousin or uncle, one of
those. It was a family member of his
first wife. Muhammad was very close with
uh with Waraka. Waraka was
uh a Gnostic Christian. So the Hadiths
in in Bukhari talks about how Waraka
used to write down the Gospel uh and
translate it into Arabic. So you're
saying he heard it from him? He heard a
lot of stuff from Waraka. He had a
Christian scribe that used to write down
stuff for him.
Uh
he used to uh communicate with the Jews
a lot.
Uh there's a Hadith that says that the
Jews used to recite the Torah in Hebrew
and then translate it and explain it in
Arabic. There's a Hadith that says that,
authentic Hadith. So
you have where
uh Muhammad is in communion in
communication with different groups,
even pagan groups. He's in communication
with them and hearing things, hearing
traditions, hearing these stories and
fables. There's There's even a verse in
the Quran, bro, there's a couple of
them, where the people The people accuse
Muhammad. They say, "These are fables
that we heard before. Like this isn't
nothing new. You know, he's just copying
uh what what someone is telling him cuz
we These are our fables."
I think the last in among them there are
those who abuse the prophet and said,
"He is an ear."
Say it an ear of goodness.
For you that have belief in Allah,
believe in with right? Mercy.
>> mind?
He said he did he just repeats
everything that he hears.
>> the disbelievers said.
But they
said they're telling stories. He's
telling stories.
>> That they already know.
They already know this this stuff. These
are traditions that are within their own
communities. So, they're like, you're
not a you're not a prophet, dude. You're
just repeating stories that of old that
we already know. These are traditions,
you know?
So,
>> knew these. This is this isn't
miraculous revelation to Muhammad. It's
he's repeating stuff. Um and a lot of
stuff he repeats it it's wrong
information cuz they're fables, you
know?
Um
So, that that's why it's like that's why
I asked the question when you're looking
at what Muhammad is saying about these
people in the past, how are you
verifying that the Quran is getting the
stuff right? Cuz if you were to ask me,
if I read the Quran, I'm like, oh, this
is what he's saying about Moses, Joseph,
Jesus, Abraham, Ishmael. He has all he
has these stories that he's saying. Let
me go double-check with the original
information, which would be the Torah,
to see if this lines up.
Which it doesn't.
Okay. What about like Surah Yusuf? I
mean, that's that lines up pretty well,
doesn't it?
>> Not really.
Uh [laughter]
So, that that what the it's actually
Surah Yusuf is really good. Um because
and uh but Surah Yusuf is I think
chapter
That's chapter 12.
>> Yeah. Yeah, Yunus Yunus is chapter 10.
Yeah. Um but
Um yeah, your question about Joseph,
right? Joseph's story. So, there's even
stuff details with Joseph's story that
he that he gets wrong. For example, uh
life
uh the Joseph story, right? Um the
difference between the Quran and what
the what he what he says about how
Joseph got into slavery. What What does
he say What does the Quran say? Yeah, so
on the Joseph story in the Quran, it
says that Joseph went I mean, in the
Bible it says Joseph went to go find his
brothers.
The Quran tells the story where the
brothers are actually pre-telling,
"Hey, Israel, Jacob, can you send him
out with us tomorrow?"
And so he tells the story completely
backwards and he tries to foretell the
story uh with the ending already in the
presupposition at the beginning of the
conversation. While the Bible tells the
story completely different. The brothers
pull Joseph out of the pit in the Quran,
the uh traveler a traveler a water boy
pulls him out of the pit. And there's a
bunch of other details too, I don't want
to overwhelm you, but those are just
two.
Yeah. So which
>> backwards? And and it's
and it's important because uh Joseph's
how he got out of the pit is what
propels the the rest of his story. How
he went how he got to to Egypt as a
slave and all of that, you know, so all
that those are not just minor details we
can just ignore. These are really
important. So Muhammad's retelling these
stories cuz he's hearing these
traditions, but he's telling them wrong.
And how do we know that he's wrong? Cuz
we have the original source to look at.
We have the Torah.
If I give them one easier one to
understand cuz that one's a little bit
more complex.
Uh in Luke 1
Do you remember the story of Zechariah?
Okay, so Zechariah couldn't speak for
the entire term of the pregnancy.
In your Quran it says three nights.
That's the clearest
like retelling of a story that's wrong.
That's like you saying you talked to God
logically today and he had a red shirt
on and orange shorts. That's just
completely wrong. It's easy to know.
Okay, how do you mess up on that detail
if you're hearing from God?
So you got to investigate it, you know,
just got to look into it.
>> don't I ain't trying to over I don't
like I don't know, man. I don't know. I
I still believe in the in the in the
Quran though. So tell so yes. I don't
know cuz I'm I'm convinced that he could
have just heard all this stuff and just
put it all together. Like it seems like
he 80% of the Quran has been I'm not
convinced of that. So what what what
what is it about the Quran? Like let's
let's let's get to the meat of of why
you believe it then. What what would you
say is the crux of the matter of what
convinced you what convinces you that
Islam is the truth? That the Quran is
the truth. What what is it?
Well, let me say this.
>> Okay.
What started me looking into the Quran
was uh this this experience I had. Um
I um
I was I was watching uh
a pastor online. Mhm. And he was talking
about Islam. Yeah. Talking about
everything why it's wrong. And he said
and he was using strong language to talk
about Prophet Muhammad. Yeah. And
something in my mind, I don't know, it
just I just I just felt this feeling of
like uh stress almost. Like something in
my mind was telling me this is not the
truth. Like what he's saying is
fundamentally wrong in some way. Mhm.
And I was a Christian at the time and I
thought, "Well, you know, I don't
believe Muhammad is is a prophet. So so
why am I getting this feeling like what
this Christian is saying is is so
fundamentally wrong while I'm listening
to this while I'm listening to him
condemn Prophet Muhammad because
because I I feel like, you know, with a
person like Prophet Muhammad, he either
is somebody everybody should follow or
he's somebody nobody should follow.
Agreed. Right? He either is a prophet,
the greatest human being, or he is like
>> prophet and one of the worst. Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly. So why do I feel
this
this um reservation, hesitation? Why
does Why does it feel wrong what this
pastor is saying about Prophet Muhammad?
So it got me thinking.
And And when I read the Quran, I I began
reading the Quran, it talks about those
who deny the truth,
right? How
Oh, I got to sneeze, but it's not coming
out. No, go ahead. I'm listening to you.
It talks about those who deny the truth,
right?
And how like
Excuse you. Okay, finally. Thank you.
It talks about those who deny the truth,
right? And how like
um
how
Mhm.
Actually, let's let's look at it.
You know, in Surah Al-Baqarah
you know
um So, is this uh going to be up the
line of what convinced you? Yeah, it is.
It is. It is. It is.
Uh
Actually, I maybe I can't find the
verse, but the point is like uh it talks
about how like um
Allah has set a seal on their eyes and
on their ears and on their hearing and
on their hearts, and that's why they
don't believe. That's why they feel
compelled to deny the truth. And I
thought to myself, maybe this is what
I'm doing with with Prophet Muhammad.
Maybe maybe that's why I'm assuming that
he's not a prophet because I have the
seal over my heart and over my eyes. And
maybe and maybe and maybe this feeling
that I'm having, I should trust it.
Does that make sense? This feeling that
I have that it's wrong what this man is
saying about him. Maybe I should trust
that feeling and investigate this
further. Maybe maybe there is some
blindfold over my eyes. I don't know.
So, what And that's what got me thinking
about it.
>> That that's So, I I understand that. So,
what what was it that you investigated
that convinced you that he was a true
prophet?
Cuz that I I I understand the build-up.
I understand huh?
I don't
I have some reservation of what this guy
is saying about him. You know, it it
currently you're you're you're not aware
of Muhammad and his prophet hood. You
know, you know, you don't you don't have
a dog in the fight. So, you want to
you're curious now. Like, wait, hold on
a second. Like, who is this guy? Let me
go check and see
what's up. So, you investigate him. So,
in investigating him, there's something
there that convinced you like, okay,
yep, this is the truth.
So, what was that?
Um
It was a lot of small things. But, but
like
Okay, so so
Hm.
I don't know if I should say this or
not.
Be as honest as you can.
Hm.
>> [snorts]
>> Cuz I want to understand you as best I
can.
So.
>> [laughter]
>> Really.
Okay.
Um
Yeah, so um
No, I just I
Um
Just
Was it prophecies? Was it consistency?
Was it
uh
What was it? Did you have a dream?
No, it
wasn't really any of that stuff. It was
just a lot of little things. I I I I
think I think I think maybe what needs
to happen is that we just need to
to just um to just try and read the
Quran with an unbiased lens. So, I've
done that. Oh, you have? You read the
whole thing?
>> Whole thing, bro. I read the whole
thing. That's that's
You know, I I encourage people to read
the Quran. To be educated on it. What
did you think about when Allah talks
about um
his signs, right? Like
where it talks about like birds as a
sign or like Bible says the same thing.
>> weather patterns as a sign. Bible says
the same thing.
>> says the same thing about birds? It says
all of creation speaks to the glory of
God. Okay, no, no, no, but I mean like
specifically about about birds like as a
sign for those who believe. You know
what I mean? I I found that very
interesting when I read the Quran. Like
why is that a sign for those who
believe? And you know, it's just
Mhm.
I'm afraid of how much I should say, but
like um
No, I mean
it's it's things like that or like where
or or or like even or even the verse
that I was talking about before like um
Uh brother, the the Bible says that when
you look at creation, it all speaks to
the glory and the existence of God. And
that how we can see his nature and his
character through creation by what he's
created. It's all of creation is our
signs that point to God. That's what
Romans chapter 1 teaches. Um so I I
understand what you're saying. Like I
understand what the Quran is saying.
Like when you have it talks about like
have they not do they not see the
heavens and the earth and the stars and
the design of them, you know? Uh
believing in Allah and stuff like that.
So yeah.
But but how do you know like
that that's that's not what's going to
convince you that okay, yeah, but
Muhammad is the true prophet or that
this
Quran is the true word of of God cuz
multiple religious books say the same
thing.
>> right, right. Well, maybe maybe I'm not
explaining myself as best as I as I
could.
>> Okay. But
I mean
um
And and again and again
I I could be totally honest, but
like okay, okay, here's another
experience that I had that mixed got me
started to think about this, right? So
so
Uh maybe I shouldn't share.
Um but but but
I just want you to be honest with what
convinced you.
If if it's uh just reading the Quran and
how the Quran talks about it talks about
God, is that what
convinced you?
Yeah, yeah, it it it's it's like I was
convinced by like things about well, the
signs of Allah, like it's talking about
like of different races as signs, the
alternation of day and night as a sign,
Okay. the alternation of clouds, the of
winds, um
talking about birds as a sign, Yeah.
things of this nature, like So would you
agree that
cuz I can agree with you that all of
those things are signs cuz both our
scriptures say that. Would you agree
that that alone doesn't demonstrate that
the Quran is from God, but that cuz
there's multiple books that are saying
this? Well, I mean
uh
I mean
cuz cuz I've I've I've I I didn't I
didn't necessarily want to say this at
the beginning, but I've actually read
the the entire Bible. Okay.
>> I've read the entire thing, the King
James version, and I don't see anywhere
where it's talking about
where it goes specifically into the
signs of God in the in the same way that
the the Quran
>> What? Oh, bro, hold on a second.
Let me show you, bro.
Have you you said you you read the book
of Job?
Yeah, I've I've read the book of Job.
You read the book of Job, and you're
telling me you haven't seen God go into
details on the signs that point to him?
Hold on, man.
Are you talking about like
What's on your mind? Go ahead, share it.
God begins
speaking
with Job. You can pull this up.
All right. So, Job chapter 38.
After Job has been complaining and stuff
like that,
God then finally answers Job.
He begins to speak to him.
All right.
So, this is what Yahweh says. This is
God speaking. It says, "Then Yahweh
answered Job out of the whirlwind and
said,
Who is that Who is this that darkness
that darkens counsel by words without
knowledge?
Now, gird up your loins like a man, and
I will ask you, and you make me know."
So, because he was questioning him, God
is now challenging him. You're going to
sit in this hot seat. You know, I'm
going to I'm going to question you, and
you're going to explain these things to
me.
He says, "Where were you when I laid the
foundation of the earth?
Tell me if you have if you know
understanding. Who sets its
measurements, since you know? Or who
stretched the line on it?
On what were its basis sunk? Or what Who
laid it its cornerstone?
When the morning stars sang together all
and all the sons of God shouted for joy?
Or who enclosed the sea with doors when
bursting forth went out from from the
womb? When I made a cloud its garment
and dense gloom its its swaddling band?
And I placed boundaries on it and and
set
set a bolt and doors. And I said, "Thus
far you shall come, but no farther. And
here shall you shall your proud waves
stop." So, he's explaining how
he set boundaries on the ocean floor and
the waters and the and and how they
don't surpass what he set for them. And
how these are signs to him. No, but he
but he's not talking about signs there.
He's just saying what he did.
>> He's not talking about signs though.
Like the Quran specifically mentions
signs for people to look at this sign.
Right? A sign is supposed to indicate
something, right? So so so the Quran
lists birds and the alternation of day
and night and the and the patterns of of
how, you know, even clouds move, things
like this. And he says that they're
signs for people who who believe and for
people of understanding. Watch this.
But But this is just saying what God No,
it's it's it's it's saying what God did
as a sign that he is God to Job. So Job
been questioning God and wondering about
him and doubting and and putting God in
a judgment seat, God responds by
pointing to things that he's done in
creation demonstrating signs of his
sovereignty and his existence. Right.
Right.
>> what I'm saying? Right. I I I get that.
I get that.
So I I it's it's consistent.
Here's a another one in general, the one
I was talking about earlier.
It says um
Let's see. For the wrath of God is
revealed from heaven against all
ungodliness and unrighteousness of men
who suppress the truth in
unrighteousness because that which is
known about God is evident within them
for God made it evident to them.
For since the creation of the world his
invisible attributes, both his eternal
power and divine nature, have been
clearly seen being understood through
what he has what has been made so that
they are without excuse.
So he says that everything that has been
made
are signs and evidences to God and who
he is, his power, and his nature. Yeah.
So the the Bible says the same the same
thing that the Quran is saying and
pointing to creation as signs that God
has that God is real and only God could
have done this.
>> I I I agree with you. I agree with you.
You know, um
Yeah.
Uh what you showed me is interesting.
However, I still I still hold fast to my
prophet.
>> I want to know why.
If he contradicts the prophets from
before, if he's not saying anything
special, what is it about him that holds
you to still believe in him as a
prophet?
Uh,
I
You don't know?
I I know, but I just I
I just
I mean, you you asked a very good
question. I know you're putting me on
the spot, and you're asking me why I
believe, but
I I just have to be honest with you.
Like, I
I I I think I think the alternative to
Islam being true
to to to some extent is is ridiculous.
Like, I I I don't think it's possible
that he
I I I don't I don't I I think like
like
The experience I had when I when I heard
that preacher, I I just felt like in my
mind when I'm hearing him say all these
bad things about Prophet Muhammad.
>> Yeah. Like, this feeling inside me was
telling me he's not being honest. He's
not being genuine. He's not telling the
full truth about something. And you
wanted to investigate.
>> Yeah, I wanted to investigate. So so so
when you Did you investigate what
Muhammad's behavior, his character? His
his Do you know about his marriage with
Aisha? Yeah, I know about his marriage
with And you're okay with that? Okay,
where does the Bible condemn what he
did? Okay, you're a Christian, your
final authority is the Bible. Where does
the Bible condemn what Prophet Muhammad
did by marrying Aisha and consummating
and marrying marrying Aisha when he did?
Sure. at that age.
>> I got you.
This is 1 Corinthians
chapter 7.
And so if the Bible condemns it, then
you'll condemn it?
Um,
Let's just see what the Bible has to
say. Okay.
Okay, look.
So, this is 1 Corinthians chapter 7
verse 36. It says,
"But if any man thinks that he is acting
unbecomingly toward his virgin daughter,
meaning he's received a virgin to be
married.
>> "If she is past her youth,
and it and and if it must be so, right?
So, it has She has to be past her youth.
Let him do what he wishes. He does not
sin. Let her marry."
She has to be past her youth. She can't
be a a child. She has to be past her
youth, a young woman, in order to be
married. Okay, interesting. Interesting
because what what version of the Bible
was that? This is
uh LSB.
A leg- Legacy Standard Bible. Yeah, cuz
cuz I was I was thinking more along the
lines
Excuse me. Along the lines of the King
James because when I read in the King
James, what it says is the flower of her
age.
>> Yeah, same thing. She has to be past her
her youth or the flower of her youth.
The flower of her
>> she had to have have reached puberty,
right? Oh, it's not It's not just
puberty. It's
>> of age. That's what it's referring to.
Like flowers, like like like Isn't that
Isn't
>> She's grown.
>> Isn't that what the flower of of your
age is referring to? Puberty? It's not
not just not not just puberty, but
growth or like maturity. So, she has to
have reached She has to be past the
flower of her youth or her age, meaning
she's not a child anymore. She's a young
woman.
Once she and and that's that's a
case-by-case basis, obviously. But once
she is a young woman,
then she is able to be married off. You
You'll see this uh with
throughout throughout the scriptures.
Like, for example, Jesus calls a
12-year-old a little girl. Her name was
Tabitha that he healed. She was 12 years
old. He said she's a little girl. So,
obviously, no, you know? So, she has to
be a young woman. Yeah, well, what I was
taught in church he said like
a flower of her age.
Like
Like Yeah, that that doesn't just mean
hitting her you're getting your period
because you get your period you're still
it's a kid. There's 8-year-olds that
have gotten their periods before.
There's That was actually going to be my
point, right? Like like he he waited
until she had reached puberty before he
consummated the marriage. So, she had
reached the flower of her age when he
when he when he was uh No, brother. No,
brother. So, so two things. Number one
flower of your age doesn't mean oh, you
started to bleed. So, therefore you can
breed now.
Because like we said an 8-year-old can
get her period. That doesn't mean she's
past the flower of her age. Would you
agree? She's still a child, right?
Well well, I mean
um
I believe you're using the term flower
of her age to mean
uh
Okay. Okay. So, so, so, so You you would
agree that a girl who gets a period at
eight is still a child, right?
I would agree she she's still a child,
but she is past the flower of her age.
Okay.
So,
you're uh
you don't have a problem with a man
having relations with let's say an
8-year-old who has had her period?
Um
Look, um here's the thing about that,
right? I believe
God is the one who told Prophet Muhammad
to marry Aisha at that age. Okay? I
believe God is the one who
did that
orchestrated that.
And
you know
I think it is strange to us,
but
I believe that's what God said. So, so
that's that's that's what goes. I got
you.
I got you.
I think that um
you know, you're going to
I just want to suggest you let you think
about this, brother. Sure.
If there is something that uh
that claims to be God
and
commands something
and permits something that is as evil
and disgusting as child abuse
it is upon us to be able to use our
discernment to say that's not of God.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> that's what Jesus warns us about, bro.
Jesus warns us about many false prophets
that will come after him who claim to
come from God and claim to be in line
with him but they'll be false prophets
and they'll deceive many people.
And they'll deceive many people into
making excuses for child abuse like
this.
And so we're we're we're at a day and
age where
you know, we got good brothers like
yourself.
Um you're genuine person from what I've
you know, I've judged in our
conversation. And I I genuinely believe
you that you believe what you believe.
And so
you uh you're you're following a
religion and a man
who is telling you that God permits
child abuse.
But you're saying that well, God lets
God's God said it's okay, so it's good.
>> people get married at younger ages in
the past like Isn't that isn't that
isn't that a thing like
>> That doesn't make it right. If someone
got if someone if people got raped in
the past
that doesn't mean that it was ever okay.
Okay, yeah, I I agree. So the Bible
The Bible, the Quran, they both
explicitly condemn rape, okay?
>> The Quran doesn't. It doesn't condemn
rape? There's not a There's not a verse
in the Quran that condemns rape,
brother.
There's not There's not one verse.
I know I know that's a crazy claim, but
it's there's not one verse in the Quran
that condemns rape.
Yeah, just yeah, think about this a
little bit. Think about it. Um you know,
consider
uh the you said you investigated
Muhammad, right? And so,
what I want you to do
going forward from here, I would
encourage you
to investigate what we what we brought
today. Okay. And
you know, if you you're genuine about
truth and you're genuine about
um
about, you know, being in right standing
with God,
that even if the ev- you follow that
means you follow the evidence where it
leads, even if it goes against what you
currently believe, like you did before,
right? So, do the same thing now. I
would say, revisit this case on Muhammad
being a prophet based on the claims he
made,
being in line with the previous
scriptures,
being mentioned in the previous
scriptures.
Um
you know, being a good example of moral
excellence. Investigate these things.
And uh
I'm curious to see what you'll what
you'll what you'll find out, okay?
>> Okay. Okay, maybe. Well, yeah. Yeah,
thank you. It was a it was an awesome
conversation, man. It was very nice
talking to you, Mark. Yeah. You live
close to here? Uh no, I I I live further
up north. Oh, okay.
For sure. Well, yeah, it was good
talking to you, man. Again, my name's
Avery, bro.
And uh
yeah, uh this was uh we can we we try to
come here to to, you know,
get people to think a little differently
and consider some some different things,
you know? So, yeah.
Yeah, some people uh take these
conversations a little to heart, you
know?
>> be offended by people of other
religions.
>> Yeah, man.
>> that's my feeling. Yeah, I agree. I
agree.
Yeah, we're probably going to get some
foods and stuff like that, but you take
care of yourself, okay? It was so nice
meeting you, Mark.
>> I'll see you.
It's God. [music]
It's God.
>> [singing]
>> Imagine.
It's God.
Imagine.